in my many years on youtube i have had
on occasion been insulted
had my honor besmirched my dignity
shamed
but never more than with the odd case
of delmonte you may or may not know this
but i
like delmonte corn or at least
i did until i professed my profound
love for their corn and asked for a
humble sponsorship
of which they refused to give me why i
ask
i don't know it makes no sense but i am
here
to rectify what has been wronged and you
may ask what has been wrong because
del monte has reached out to me oh yes
they asked for my address and they said
that they were going to send me
a gift and i thought wow they need to
send me a big fat
check hopefully a comically oversized
one for all the promotion that i have
done for them
over the months but all the promotional
material of which
has thus been deleted i will give you
so much if you can guess what
they gave to me as a gift it makes the
gifts from sour patch kid looks like
booze
big bouncy boons smash the like button
if you think you know what
delmonte corn gave to me i will offer
you guys
a free subscription to my channel where
you will be updated of any video that i
post
at any time and and including a free
bell with that if you can guess
what they sent to me the present that
they deemed worthy for me
markiplier the one who was professing
his love to all the heavens for their
corn
was 24 cans of corn
they didn't even send a letter they
literally sent me
a box of corn there was a letter
where was the letter oh okay they
didn't send a letter if they did send a
letter it was so insulting that i didn't
keep it and you can see
i tried to eat the corn i tried to be
happy about it i tried to go for it with
a smile on my face but i only got two
cans in
and then suddenly sadness overtook me
you think you can find it i think it's
in here
no yes here it is oh remember because we
got
this in the mail before the corn oh
right
oh my god i forgot about that burning
breaking news bulletin i forgot about
that important detail
so before this arrived before this
magical gift arrived this
blessing of corn this ten dollars worth
of corn
came in the mail i received a letter
dear markiplier it doesn't say dear
markiplier but i'm just assuming that
they wanted to be polite
which is a bold assumption markiplier
del monte foods would like to thank you
for your unwavering support of the
canned whole
colonel corn we've seen the videos the
means
and we've chuckled notice they didn't
laugh your search for
thick water led you to del monte somehow
and we sincerely appreciate your
endorsements
for our brand in return for your support
we are gifting you these cans of corn
you can use them however you please but
we provided some recipes for you to test
out
now imagine my surprise when i got this
letter
and there were no cans of corn to be
found what a strange letter to get
was this a threat were they going to
bombard my house with corn
where was this corn coming from and when
the corn finally arrived
without a check and no contract to sign
for a long-term two-year deal of
exclusivity to delmonte abraham corn
imagine my surprise they thought so
little of me that they thought i
couldn't afford
24 cans of corn
it cost more to ship that than it would
have cost me to buy that
and the recipes that they got here is um
southwest garden sloppy joes who puts
corn in sloppy joe's two-minute corn
salsa i
don't like corn and my salsa and a
frittata
do i look like the kind of person that
can make a frittata or even knows what a
frittata is
what is a frittata okay whatever it
doesn't matter look this is an insult
and i will not stand for it i have
stanned
delmonte for months and and
all in my life i've stayed in del monte
but it is time
to understand that my love will never be
reciprocated in the monetary form that
it deserves to be reciprocated but i
know
of one other one
big greenhearted other
i don't have it here with me i gotta go
get it get your stupid corn
i realized i never liked del monte
there was always something about it you
know the corn just didn't taste right it
didn't
taste fresh you know what i mean it
wasn't quite like it was picked off of
the tree
you know i just felt like it was a
little over processed a little too long
steeped in the water
well there's another oh yes there's
another
and he is jolly and he's big
he is the jolly green giant that's right
i'm all about green beans now because
let me tell you something something
about corn water
it's too sweet why not just drink a soda
which isn't good for you
huh why not slug down some sour patch
kids which are just pure sugar
and that's not good for anybody if you
want pure nutrition
you have to get the deliciousness that
is green giant green beans
and this is actually a fact about my
childhood when it came down to getting
vegetables for you know
as the side dish for your meat and two
veggies we would have some meat
and then we would add corn and green
beans and let me tell you something
the corn might have been okay but the
green beans
was where the real nutrition came from
and let me tell you something about the
green giant
he's got big juicy green beans there's
something that i can say with confidence
it's that i markiplier love
jolly green giant's green beans
that is much more palatable than del
monte corn because i think if you
remember i mean the archival footage has
long been deleted but i think if you
remember
if you think back to me trying del monte
corn i had to choke that down
it wasn't good at all but this
goes down smooth i can drink that all
day
low calorie and filling and chock full
of vitamins and minerals
just for you picked right off of the
jolly greens giants beanstalk
and now that i'm thinking about it i'm
pretty sure it wasn't del monte that was
there throughout my entire childhood
they wouldn't be there for anybody that
needed them it was the jolly green giant
i remember being embraced in his jolly
green arms
jolly green giant i expect a sponsorship
very soon
or else i like the fickle [ __ ] that i
am will turn on you
just like i did del monte but in the
meantime
hey here's a helpful tip if you want to
enjoy a nice can of green beans
why not crack some fresh ground pepper
into there
and eat it that's right you can eat the
beans too you don't just have to drink
them
do you guys think i'm joking about this
no i'm not joking about this this is
life
that's real life right now and this was
my life this is actually what i did when
i was growing up all the time if there
was just canned vegetables i would crack
up in a can
i wouldn't heat them up or anything just
crack open the can and eat a little salt
give that a little few tosses in there
like it down a bit yeah that's good
stuff
and literally
this is why i did actually this is what
i still do
but in case i'm doing it now you can't
prove anything you don't know my life
i'm telling you my life how why would i
lie
i love green giant you know they're
green beans
just better in every way than del
monte's green beans
i'll tell you something green giant
knows fresh
del monte knows preserved i've got to
give them that they really can make that
stuff last and they do but
green giant it's always fresh probably
because they're flying off the shelves
because everyone's buying them if you
buy yourself a can of green giant green
beans
why don't you post it on twitter tag
them tell them
maybe you should give mark a sponsorship
i'm actually legitimately gonna finish
it
i don't know why i have the second
camera set up maybe for the detail shots
maybe we'll just zoom in a lot in
quality
so you can really see that yeah so
that's the stuff look at that
look at that now that's a jelly green
giant
oh
that's a good duck but it doesn't end
there jolly green giant also provides
top quality jolly green yellow corn now
if you want some whole
sweet kernel corn you have to reach down
for
jolly green giant it is
far superior here i'll even compare the
ingredients
jolly green giant corn golden whole
colonel corn water and salt
literally the salt of the earth can't
get any fresher than that meanwhile
delmonte
what's over here huh corn water and salt
not
golden whole colonel corn i'm not even
lying about this let's just
zoom in on this [ __ ] you know what i
don't even care if it's a salesman taco
it is just showmanship look ingredients
focus golden whole colonel corn
meanwhile del monte
look at look at look at this chad green
giant versus
virgin del monte or the corn water and
salt
yeah we got corn in the can i guess a
little bit meanwhile green giant
we have golden whole colonel corn
i'll think of beauty unbeatable in every
way pathetic they don't even have a
mascot
and look proud supporter of st jude's
children's research hospital
more like the golden green hero
quarantine's getting to me but hey it's
always a brighter day and there's always
someone to
make fun of look on the bright side
there's always something to complain
about
and i always do have something to
complain about and uh frankly this this
video isn't just about del monte but
i have something else to complain about
i'm not sure if i'm supposed to put
hashtag ad on this because
much like the sour patch thing i didn't
ask for the corn
they just kind of sent me the corn and
then the recipes i guess have some
inherent value but
frankly i'm not gonna put ad not only
just because i don't think it's ad
i wasn't paid for any of this not yet
anyway but also because i'll just let
them fight over it because
if there's two different companies i'm
not really endorsing either of them
they can argue with it for themselves
because i have another bone to pick
with sour patch kids because they sent
me another box
and and you know what you know you know
you know i'm thinking what i'm thinking
is
they're just constantly sending me
things hoping that i'll open it on a
video
and give them some glowing endorsement
or give them some exposure and i'm no
fool
because i'm gonna open it on a video
which is what they want but i'm not
gonna be happy about it you see what i
mean
it's not all press is good prep all
exposure good exposure all
all publicity is good all publicity is
good publicity
not here i don't even know what's in
here because i i opened this box
saw sour patch kids this was like months
ago amy how long ago was this this was
like
five or six months ago like a year ago
they sent me
whatever this is i think it was in
celebration
of opening their store they had a sour
patch kids
store that were they were opening really
bad
timing for that kind of really
unfortunate timing for them to open a
physical store
right as covid struck so i don't know
what there is to endorse i don't even
know if they still
have a store i don't even know if that's
a thing that's still happening
but either way i don't endorse it
straight up i don't care what's in this
box
i don't endorse it because it's about
staying safe and there's no way that
sour patch kids is an essential business
but let's see what's inside shall we oh
what is this
this recipes is this actually more
recipes
this is this is more recipes they sent
me a
that they sent me recipes
i am not going to cook with sour patch
kids there is no point
at which i would be so desperate that i
would cook with sour patch kids
in what world would i do that i am not
going to be in your test kitchen
making up new horribly cursed sour patch
recipes for you to sell
where's the sour patch cream cheese you
didn't have the balls for it
and now you're crawling back to me
anyway considering i am
the sour patch review channel maybe
someday i will try these recipes
but that is very unlikely unless you
guys get me
that green giant sponsorship or leave
enough likes on this video
or subscribe to see it in the future
those are the only circumstances that it
will happen
what else do we have here a cup
a tumbler sorry it's 13
seems a little pricey doesn't even come
with a straw wait there's a straw hole
but no straw
those cheap skates oh there it is okay
never mind they're not cheap
they're pricey they can spend all this
dosh
on this stuff for me and yet they can't
afford
to actually pay me money for a
sponsorship
you know what i mean this it could be
the greatest
sponsorship in the history of youtube
and yet
they are trying to play me they're
trying to play me they're trying to pass
me off
with these these peasant rewards when i
should be getting a big
fat check with a del monte and a
green giant and a sour patch kid
sponsorship and yet i have
nothing i get a box i get cans of corn
in a box
i get recipes i have to go buy more sour
patch kids they didn't even put it in
here there's no sour patch kids in here
i had to buy it
maybe there's sour patch kids in here i
haven't gotten to it we got socks
those are tacky got a shirt that's
actually not bad
i actually like that i like the style of
that that's not bad is it my
size
they didn't even get my size right how
can they not even ask
what my size is how impersonal
do they get there wasn't even a note
with this one by the way there wasn't
even a letter it was just a box
they didn't even bother to ask me to try
to disclose anything so i won't
so it's their fault if i get in trouble
why do they not even
ask what my size i am the sour patch
review channel
amy i'm the sour patch review channel
right right
right without question
yeah i'm telling them i'm lisa
garbage
that was cool sunglasses well at
first i was going to be like hey at
least they're not tacky
and then i saw the back
blocking out the haters oh they did send
me sour patch kids okay they did send me
sour patch kids
well fools on them because i'm on a diet
alex is already mad at me
so i can't even eat these but i will
because i'm angry and i'm emotional and
i need to compensate something and i
just can't have green beans for dinner
so i gotta have something
i like the art i'm not gonna lie i like
it
maybe i'm never gonna get that
sponsorship i deserve i just want a
partner you know
i just want a company that's gonna treat
me like i should be treated like the
glorious youtube god that i
am handsome huge dick like come
on treat me good oh god that's
creepy oh man it's just a bag god you're
not gonna
it's just a bag it's just a bag it's you
got this nice ass box
and you're just gonna shove a bag into
it what is wrong with you
it's a bag in a box what's the point of
the box then
oh they couldn't have come up with
anything a bit more creative
than just a shoving a bag in there i
don't know why i'm upset
i was expecting like you know a box of
chocolate style thing where they had
like individual like
sections for it like they were separated
by color or maybe like
they were it looked like new york you
know the city escape like it was
sectioned out like the city
that would have been cool not a bag you
got this nice collector's tin that you
got here like this is really cool the
art's good this is neat it stands up on
its own no
it's got bag in it god damn it what is
wrong with you where's my check
like this video if you think i deserve a
check or a contract i take a contract
that guarantees multiple checks
throughout the year whatever i'm done
suffering from success it's so it's so
hard at the top
but without sponsorships what am i
really
do i even know who i am where am i going
in my life
who even am i i don't even know anymore
but where am i gonna get this
sponsorship the one blessed by the gods
look some things just don't happen to
good people
and even if i'm a good person nadia was
always gonna get what i deserve
that is delicious green giant call me
so anyway like this video if you liked
it or if you're upset
at del monte in my stead and sour patch
kids in my
favor or whatever i might make another
one depending on
whether or not i get what i deserve and
heck maybe
getting what i deserve is sour patch
assassins coming after me and trying to
silence me
so if i wind up with a sour patch bullet
in my head
you know who did it or a corn bullet not
like they know where i live
anyway thank you everybody so much for
watching do subscribe if you want to see
more videos like this
i've got a lot more coming this way and
i promise it won't be all yelling at
companies
unless you want that kind of stuff and
then i'm going to be yelling at a lot of
companies
might not always be angry yelling might
be yells of ecstasy
and excitement you never know gotta
subscribe to see so thank you
and as always i will see you in the next
video
bye bye